you just said a moment ago this can be
fixed in a week
how just go back to doing what we were
doing in december
all you have to do is talk to the board
of patrol members
uh they'll tell you straight up all we
have to do is go back to what we were
doing
before president obama president uh
freudian slip president biden undid
everything that the republican congress
and the trump administration did
easy peasy done it'll be fixed in a week
simple solution from gop center john
kennedy is he right
as the migrant crisis on our border
intensifies so while the white house
calls for federal volunteers
congressional delegates from texas are
visiting the border to assess the
situation for themselves
well retired acts uh acting ice director
tom homan
and texas congressman chip roy will take
part they join us right now good morning
both of you
good morning congressman roy uh you know
the administration has been reluctant to
let any members of the press come down
there
and just look at it with their own two
eyes
what is it joe biden is hiding
well first of all i helped lead a letter
last week to uh
push on the administration to allow
press to get down at the border and
today i hope to
take some press with me directly down to
the rio grande you know i go to the
border frequently i've been there
two weeks ago i went to laredo saw
firsthand uh in fact i was being
interviewed by breitbart right on the
rio grande when a number of
uh illegals bolted across the river
right behind us we had to interrupt the
interview while cbp had to stop them
i was there when we had a hundred
detentions right when i was sitting
there on the river but
the reality is that president biden
doesn't want the american people to know
that it's his policies
his specific policies his
administration's policies
that are causing this crisis and this is
a crisis we're going to have
upwards of 125 000 apprehensions in
february but that's not the whole story
because border patrol is now distracted
running processing facilities in mcallen
and now we've got massive amounts of
narcotics coming up between the ports of
entry
and we've got the cartels exploiting it
for profit i had the
district attorney of bernie texas a
suburb of san antonio
call me all sorts of frustrated because
they encountered a car load of illegals
one of whom was a boy and paid four
thousand dollars to go
work for a vineyard in california but lo
and behold he was being taken to a stash
house
to be put into human trafficking they
nabbed the cartel guy behind it
and then they took it to the feds and
the feds won't do anything about it
that's the story that joe biden doesn't
want the american people to know
cartels are getting full operational
control of our border
they've got control of mexico and it's
all because they stopped doing
the policies of president trump which
was actually tough on the on the border
tom ted cruz just went down there and he
said what he saw was just
he said it's the worst he's ever seen he
said they're renting out
babies and they'll use the same babies
or same little children over and over
and over
uh just so they can get into the country
have you seen anything like that
well yes actually when i was ice
director we had numerous investigations
on children being rented by cartels
they'd be they'd be put with a adult
male adult female to claim a family
group and then they got released by a
border patrol the child be sent back
to be re-rented i mean look i didn't
wait i'm not waiting for today i
actually went out there last night uh as
soon as i flew in the town
we got out there and within 20 minutes
within 20 minutes i saw two separate
groups
by the time we're done about 180 they
walked out of the brush
and turned themselves into border patrol
there's two things i want to share first
of all
the fox network one board glaze i heard
someone yell iceman which is kind of my
nickname
i turn around board ladies and walks up
to me and thanks me and thanks fox
network for telling the truth they said
his words his words
their bosses the secretary and president
won't mention crisis
so thank god fox news is obviously
that's the talk of the station that
fox news is telling the story the second
thing i want to say is i saw compassion
last night
i saw about seven-year-old little girl
who was scared and crying
i saw a big burly board between get down
into me
and talk to that child like it was his
child and within a few minutes she
cracked a smile
so unlike what the president said these
aren't people that buy starving children
diamond ribbon banks these
absolutely congressman you know what the
key is tom holman worked for two
administrations
the democratic republican you have
congressman cuellar and gonzalez
uh you have to get democrats with you
who obviously congressman cuellar gets
it who
who are just as passionate about you
because people look at
when you speak and the other side speaks
as partisan
this is a bipartisan american problem
have you done that at all
yeah i'm glad you asked that you know i
had dinner with uh henry cuellar in
laredo with border patrol two weeks ago
uh yesterday or today
and uh you know we sat down and we
talked about what we need henry and i
have introduced legislation to clear
cane and to establish a road along the
rio grande to
help border patrol do their job uh this
is a problem that i think increasingly
you know
the democrat mayor of del rio he raised
his hand up and said hey look president
biden
you guys are failing you're overrunning
our city our hospitals our schools
but also this is the important part and
tom just mentioned it
this is horrible for the immigrants the
democrats are saying they're trying to
help
they're being literally used as pawns to
make money
tens of thousands of dollars per per
individual sometimes three to seven
thousand percent
11 million dollars a day for the cartel
of the rest day
of los angeles in nuevo laredo 11
million dollars a day moving human
beings for profit
that's what's really going on president
biden now appoints
kamala harris to clean up something
where is she that is
worse because she called ice the
equivalent of the kkk
tom holman my friend here she's she's
making the brave officers of ice
and equating them to the kkk said they
should be abolished
she said she was four sanctuary cities
she's going to take what's already a bad
situation and make it worse
the way to fix this is on a bipartisan
basis understand what president trump
did was right
that we should go back to mexico have
the return to mexico policy put in place
stand up strong on title 42 and covet
and stop this crisis before it hurts
more americans and more immigrants
all right uh congressman mr homan we
know you've got to go
take a tour later today thank you very
much for joining us today here on fox
and friends
thanks john god bless you thank you god
bless you